vous vous avez un mec là sérieusement
non bah alors lancez un appel c'est que
ça marche
he bien est-ce que vous êtes
lesbo non vous êtes htéro finalement je
crois finalement vous avez découvert
qu'après tout vous étiez htéro mais je
l'étais à la base ou c'est ça l'histoire
vous a fait un petit détour par un grand
détour de 10 ans mais ça c'est devenu
une parenthèse au bout du voilà et vous
revenez maintenant à l'hétérosexualité
ouaisie ouais c'est vachement mieux moi
aussi vous avez un mec là sérieusement
non alors lancer un appel c'est que ça
marche c'est que la Rousseau prenons la
Rousseau par exemple la Rousseau a lancé
un appel dans cette émission on a trouvé
un J s'appelle Fabrice très bien grâce à
l'émission grâce à tu veux lancer un
appel plus
lance vas-y qui veut de moi voilà
problème de c'est qu'il les égorge
évidemment est-ce que vous êtes clostro
oui c'est vrai ça vous êtes très hein
c'est vrai que vous êtes rester un an
sans sortir de chez vous ouais parce que
j'étais en plus agoraphobe agoraphobe et
et et qui vous faisait les courses et
ben j'allais sur le trottoir d'en face
il y avait une épicerie donc je me suis
ruinée pendant un an acheter trucs super
cher parce que je pouvais pas sortir
ouais jusqu'à ce qu'on me dise que que
si ça continuait il allait falloir me
m'interner parce que je pouvais pas
aller chercher mes cigarettes et j'ai eu
peur et là j'ai c'est un bon moyen
d'arrêter de fumer trop en même temps
non je me suis soignée toute seule enfin
c'est pas fini mais c'est gérable mais
là ça va là ouais ça va ouais je suis
bourré de médicament est-ce que vous
êtes
NFO je crois pas
non ça veut dire
quoioman nymphomane c'est une fille qui
a besoin de beaucoup d'hommes beaucoup
de rapports sexuels dans la journé juste
pour pour le rapport en lui-même juste
pour l'acte non Rapp non vous êtes
mytho non plus je crois pas non plus
vous êtes
skizo sûrement complètement
ouais qu'est-ce que tu as toucher la
queue de mon dinosaure toi mais je le
crois pas le mec il vient to et mon fils
c'est le dinosaure de Gaston ça quand
même il vient il prend la queue de mon
dinosaure enfin s'excite tout seul
est-ce que vous êtes parano
ouais
Mao certainement comme j'aim bien qu'on
fasse mal physiquement voulez dire oui
vous faites l'amour vousimez bien qu'on
vous pin ça non ça dépend de la personne
ça dépend de j'en sais rien si un truc
qui monte ça fait pas de mal mais pas
j'ai pas besoin de ça vous êtes gérono
pardon gérono est-ce qu'and tu aime les
yeux euh pas jusqu'à maintenant non vous
êtes zo non non coco non c'est quoi coco
non non j'ai pas les moyen mais non
Toto est-ce que Adamo est-ce que est-ce
que vous êtes
Adamo mais mais on sous-estime vachement
Adamo talent oui est-ce que vous êtes
métro boulot
dodo non non ben non non vous êtes disco
non et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
deard tube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce
bleu